emma kept on texting me and she was like
are you in this new spider-man film
and i was like
i don't know what you're talking about
what you're still walking out with him
she was like shut up just tell me i'm
like i honestly don't know what i kept
it going even with her as hilarious yup
andrew garfield totally lied to emma
stone about his spider-man no way home
rule much like he did to et over the
last year there's a lot of chatter of
the is he or isn't he when it comes to
the next spider-man so let me just ask
you i don't know what you want then i
was like is he originally like what's
the where's this going
well where is it going how do you tell
me there are rumors galore that you will
be in
no way um
you oh boy i feel like i'm in a game of
werewolf and i'm just saying i'm not the
werewolf i am not the werewolf i promise
you guys i am not the werewolf um so
yeah i mean
listen what people are talking about
is a really cool idea and and and again
i haven't received a phone call but you
know
so let's recap and uh spidey spoilers
ahead andrew pops up and the latest tom
holland holland-led spider-man film as
another version of peter parker but not
to give away the big twist toby maguire
pops up too andrew kept it a secret even
to his spider-man's love interest gwen
stacy aka emma emma kept on texting me
and she was like are you in this new
spider-man film
and i was like
i don't know what you're talking about
what you're still walking out with
she was like shut up just tell me i'm
like i honestly don't know what i kept
it going even with her as hilarious he
told the story on josh horowitz's happy
sad confused podcast to the end you
never admitted to emma
no and then she and then she saw it she
was like you're a jerk yeah like uncle
ben says or aunt may if you've seen the
new movie remember
with great power
comes great responsibility and andrew
obviously took his marvel vow of secrecy
as a huge responsibility i'm so happy
that i get to talk about it now but now
the secret is out and andrew isn't
holding back i still can't believe it it
happened here's what he told et about
his big return to the spider-verse and
i'm so happy that i get to talk about it
now because it's like
i it's like i've been i've had so many
different hats on in in the sense of
like
like first and foremost i am a fan
so when
so when amy pascal and kevin feige and
and john watts
um asked to have a word with me and talk
to me about an idea and they and they
pitched it
it was like i be i was the fans in the
audience watching it on screen for the
first time with like the the three
the three spider-man across
universes are sharing a frame together
and like your hair your little head just
explodes and then the fact that i get to
be one of those people wearing the suit
next to
my actual spider-man hero toby maguire
and the the brilliant incredibly
talented heartfelt funny good sweet
perfect spiderman of tom holland and i
get to be the middle brother and i get
to be like in awe of my older brother
and in full longing to protect my
younger brother and just like and also
there's something spiritual that that
kind of happened and happens and that we
were exploring in the film which is like
you know archetypally the character is
so alone
the the isolation that that's a big
important part of the character in in
terms of the canon of spider-man for me
anyway
and i think one of the reasons why i
think it's so appealing to so many
people around the world is that feeling
of
solitude that we can all
and loneliness maybe is a better word
that we can all relate to i still can't
believe it it happened and i'm just like
you know i snuck into a theater one like
on opening night
and just watched from like with my
baseball cap on my mask and just kind of
like
and uh in fact i was actually with toby
me and toby snuck into a theater
together
no one knew we were there it was just a
really beautiful thing to share together
and to find a brotherhood with toby as
well and with tom and the fact that we
have shared
that we that we do share a very unique
experience would you do it again do you
would you put the suit on if given the
opportunity
i mean
i
you know never say never i mean it's
such it's it's a character that's always
gonna be so meaningful to me and so
beautiful to me and
again it comes back to service you know
i think
if there's a way because that's what's
that's what that character is all about
he's all about serving the greater good
and serving
his fellow
fellow people his fellow you know
serving humanity and all life you know
so if there's a way
for me to
continue to add to the legacy of that
character in a way that feels
like it's
of service to an audience of service to
the themes of you know the themes that
stan lee
kind of uh you know injected that
character with
i'm open of course i'm very very open
but but it would have to be very very
special it would have to be very very
um meaningful and um and fun and joyful
like um like doing no way home was with
oh my god man those those guys are just
incredible like john watts like the it
feels like you're just hanging out with
your best friend from like
like preschool and you're just kind of
playing and you're just like
you know anything goes kind of thing
yeah and then the same with you know
with with that tribe of of that core
gang you know like jacob and zendaya and
tom they are just
proper best friends and then me and toby
were just kind of included in that best
friendship for a period of time and it
was very generous of them yeah man i
would i would i you know it's a
beautiful character so it's always going
to be a part of me whether i'm playing
playing the character or not i feel very
connected to him
[Music]
you